bonjour ayad chaibi merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
est une visite qui intervient dans un
contexte difficile pour la tunisie
contexte économique et sanitaire
compliqué il s'agit de resserrer les
liens entre la france et la tunisie
quel est l'état des relations entre les
deux pays c'est une relation qui est
excellente
pas depuis pas depuis hier mais les
relations entre la france et la tunisie
tant d'un point de vue de la coopération
dans les diverses domaine que d'un point
de vue amical j'ai envie de dire ont
toujours été forte et elles le sont
encore plus depuis ces derniers mois on
le voit d'ailleurs par les multiples
déplacements du ministre jean yves le
drian en tunisie ou de son homologue à
paris et puis bien sûr les différents
déplacements qu'à effectuer le président
comme un caïd ça y est
en france et le chef du gouvernement
actuel hicham méfie donc par nature les
relations entre la france et la tunisie
elles sont anciennes elles sont
indéfectibles sont elles sont bonnes et
la visite effectuée aujourd'hui le
premier ministre jean castex démontre la
force de la solidarité entre nos deux
pays
oui c'est sa première visite d'envergure
à l'international pour jean castex avec
un contexte nouveau puisque il y a
effectivement cailly sayed qui a été
élue ans en 2019 il ya également un un
chef du gouvernement ils s'aiment méfie
cycle est issu du parti islamiste
ennahda
est ce que ça peut compliquer les choses
alors juste pour resituer un peu le
contexte hichem les chichis n'est pas
issu du parti ennahda il est soutenu par
une plate-forme parlementaire il y a
effectivement ennahdha mais c'est une
personnalité de la société civile
effectivement les relations entre le
chef du gouvernement et le président de
la république sont assez pour ne pas
dire complexe mais
je pense que les deux personnes sont
suffisamment responsables pour essayer
de l'avant même si c'est vrai que le
contexte ne s'y prête pas forcément
quelles sont les attentes de la tunisie
on l'a dit hier le pays à de graves
difficultés économiques notamment a créé
à cause de la crise sanitaire un
tourisme qui est qui est au plus bas en
quoi quelles sont les attentes justement
envers la france à ce sujet la tunisie
auprès de la france et surtout une
coopération économique d'envergure la
france je rappelle quand même que la
france est le premier partenaire
économique commercial et culturel de de
la tunisie donc les attentes sont
grandes
le président note finans fer notamment
bon ça a déjà été le cas la france est
engagée déjà à verser une aide
économique d'importance lorsque le jean
yves le drian s'est rendu en tunisie en
octobre 2020 donc les aides sont là mais
je pense que là la demande principale
qui a été d'ailleurs formulé par le
président kaïs à l'aide à l'occasion du
sommet sur le financement des économies
africaines c'est surtout par rapport à
la dette tunisienne aujourd'hui la
tunisie à une dette abyssale 100
milliards de dinars l'équivalent de 30
milliards d'euros
donc je pense que la question principale
si on doit vraiment aborder un sujet
c'est la question de la dette de la
réduction significative de sa dette pour
permettre une relance économique
d'envergure ou de l'annulation c'est ce
qui avait été aussi les bobos de l'anus
ou ou de l'annulation pure et simple
effectivement ce serait effectivement
préférable
allez on va parler également de la
sécurité beaucoup et du terrorisme alors
là quelles sont les attentes de la
france par rapport à la tunisie une
coopération étroite
même si celle ci est déjà le quart entre
gérald darmanin et et à ses homologues
tunisiens moi j'avais d'ailleurs proposé
puisque comme vous avez pu le le voir et
le constater aussi bien la france que la
tunisie n'a pas été épargné par les
actes terroristes des deux côtés et
c'est vrai que dès le mois de novembre
j'avais proposé la mise en place
de la sécurité pour la méditerranée avec
vraiment principalement portée par la
france et la tunisie pour justement
renforcer ce dialogue entre ce qu'on
appelait le dialogue 5 + 5 c'est à dire
les cinq pays de la rive sud avec les
cinq pays de la rive nord sur l'aspect
sécuritaire mais moi ce que je voudrais
surtout proposer puisque vont parler de
cette coopération sécuritaire notamment
dans un contexte de de terrorisme
malheureusement ti qui a frappé les deux
pays
moi je voudrais parler de ce qu'on
appelle les magistrats de liaison
c'est à dire ces fonctionnaires détachés
et qui ont pour objectif d'être les
garants du bon fonctionnement de la
relation judiciaire à ce jour la france
possède 15 magistrats de liaison dans
ses ambassades à l'étranger et elle en
accueille à peu près une dizaine 9 je
crois de mémoire sur son territoire
parmi ces neuf
vous avez un magistrat liaison marocain
affecté à l'ambassade du royaume du
maroc et puis un algérien affecté à
l'ambassade de la république algérienne
la tunisie en a pas je pense que ce
serait utile d'avoir un magistrat de
liaison tunisiens qui soit à l'ambassade
tunisienne ce qui permettrait à la fois
de renforcer la coopération judiciaire
avec la france mais également d'assurer
une transversalité avec ses homologues
du maroc et de l'algérie
question 2 du retour justement des
personnes accusées de terrorisme de
nationalité tunisienne
or tunis se montrent plutôt réticentes à
les accueillir c'est le cas oui oui ça a
été ça a été le cas lorsque gérald
darmanin s'est rendu s'est rendu à tunis
au mois de novembre il était question
justement du retour de ces de ces
personnes fichées s évidemment les
discussions étaient ont été difficiles
mais la coopération se poursuit pour
trouver la meilleure des solutions
mais c'est parce que tunis dit que ces
personnes ont été radicalisé sur le sol
français c'est l'argument invoqué qui
sont radicalisées sur le sol français où
le sur le sol tunisien
le problème le problème est le même
si effectivement la tunisie ne souhaite
pas comment dirais-je accueillir ces
éléments qui peuvent constituer une
menace pour la tunisie
bon il en va de la souveraineté de la
tunisie et qui est libre de ses choix
c'est pour ça que la sortie de comment
dirais-je de ce problème ne passe que
par le dialogue et par une coopération
renforcée entre les services judiciaires
et les services sécuritaires et je pense
qu'on peut faire confiance aux ministres
des deux pays pour trouver une solution
qui permette entre qui soit acceptable
pour les deux parties
dernière question à être cheminot est
très peu de temps l'union européenne
voudrait conditionné une aide en échange
d'un meilleur contrôle des migrants on
sait que 15% des migrants sont d'origine
tunisienne en europe
est ce que la tunisie peut avancer avec
une aide potentielle
je ne pense pas que la tunisie soit
fermée à tout tête qu'elle serait
qu'elle vient de la france ou de l'union
européenne qui par ailleurs est très et
comment dirais-je est très présente en
tunisie il ya des relations très fortes
entre l'union européenne et la tunisie
et je pense que ça sur cette question
qui est très importante
la question des flux migratoires je
pense que l'aide de l'union européenne
peut être importante pour la tunisie qui
a une expertise et puis surtout qui peut
apporter des solutions à ce problème
mais elle ne pourra pas les apporter
seul il faut qu'il y ait aussi un
dialogue de part et d'autre notamment du
côté de l'union européenne et
particulièrement de la france restent
malheureusement plus de temps pour
poursuivre ce déplacement de jean castex
merci beaucoup
ryan scheibling de nous avoir apporté
votre point de vue ce matin